[Music]
one thinking we have to try to set off a
mousetrap with a finger and with the
draw the finger before of any rules hit
the mousetrap what hit the master right
right
what's the punishment rat trap that
one's the one I'm worried about I'm not
gonna break my finger
I don't know can mousetraps break
fingers if we could break rats take a
break rats heads and stuff so well
alright let's start with I don't know
whether to do it with my left hand cuz
this I'm right-handed yeah so I don't
want I don't a bust my good hand but
this is my first hand how do we win this
challenge or lose this challenge
whoever gets farthest out of the trap so
this data oh that's really good oh yeah
I don't know probably the baby or
whether this is really gonna hurt it
would hurt like a [__] if you got you
10 the sets 1000 frames
I'm ready on the button my special
technique go though is fraction of a
second in that yeah it was good to me
cause using their I don't have the fact
that it takes after about here
[Music]
that's really close that's so fast whose
servant got the first two anything's me
so you lose on you oh is this the
there's no way that's right look at this
right right that's the comparison yeah
oh you know this is heavy dude I'm
worried about my fingers coming off you
don't need safe food
I don't plastic in my life all right big
rat trap test number 1 by row I hit me
you're right about it you need its
safety goes Jesus pieces everywhere that
is not happening that is took out the
loser booyah
I'll just go flick it flick the other
thing why is this now the scariest thing
I've ever done
you believe yourself on fire for
Christ's sake this detention oh shut
[Music]
I'm not feeling right after that big as
your hands that was filmed 40 times
slower than the real time it was still
like I couldn't even see it move I did
not see it they cannot recognize well I
reckon people watching this video want
to see someone's hand get stuck in a
mousetrap I'm not doing it no with that
really yep oh yeah whoever does it
whoever does that this to the finger
will be the here over this video you
guys do it yeah go for it yeah yeah yeah
ah
[Music]
all right
mousetrap stuff done awesome
[Music]